salut à toutes et à tous bonjour et
bienvenue dans sénat stream votre
émission de public sénat comme chaque
mercredi nous avons le plaisir de
recevoir un sénateur ou une sénatrice
qui vient répondre à vos questions cette
semaine nous recevons éric bocquet
bonjour bonjour vous êtes sénateur
communiste du nord merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation bonjour à vous qui nous
regardent et bonjour et merci de nous
suivre en ce moment sur twitter en
direct ou sur public sénat le canal 13
de la tnt éric bocquet nous allons
passer une heure à échanger avec vous
sur des sujets d'actualité on va aussi
parler de vous mais avant ça je voudrais
quand même qu'on commence par des
questions d'actualité chaude si je puis
dire c'est parti pour le moment actu
l'actualité de ces derniers jours c'est
de ces dernières semaines éric bocquet
c'est la situation dans les antilles une
crise sociale qui est en train
d'exploser la situation est en train de
s'envenimer sur fond de crise sanitaire
d' obligation vaccinale rejeté par une
partie des personnels soignants une
première question très direct
approuvez-vous l'envoi des forces du
gign et du raid en guadeloupe décidées
par le gouvernement je pense que c'était
pas le premier message à envoyer très
honnêtement
cette crise et eclancher à partir de
l'obligation vaccinale face à la crise
du coc vie des crises sanitaires mais je
crois qu'elle est révélatrice d'une
crise beaucoup plus profondes et
anciennes parce que on se souvient qu'en
2009 il y avait eu déjà des
manifestations violentes dans aux
antilles de même nature avec des
dégradations etc alors personne ne peut
approuver les dégradations les violences
les saccages c'est clair mais il faut
prendre encore une fois en compte sans
excuser les choses c'est pas ça le débat
mais
appréhender la situation sociale
économique de ces îles qui souffrent
énormément de très grande pauvreté un
taux de chômage supérieur à celui qui
existe en métropole la vie chère les
collègues l'ont exprimé dans les débats
du budget au sénat
ces derniers jours voilà les des prix
supérieurs entre 20 et 40% par rapport à
la métropole voilà la jeunesse et
l'ensemble de la population est
confrontée à cette situation là donc
c'est d'abord une réponse économique
sociale et solidaire qu'il faudra
apporter après qu'il faille du retour
alors on est d'accord que on peut pas
approuver les violences et les saccages
des incendies on tire à balles réelles
comme elle c'est grave ce qui se passe
les policiers se font tirer dessus à
balles réelles donc il faut ça peut ça
peut s'enflammer ça peut aller très très
loin c'est il faut d'urgence répondre
sur le plan social et sur le plan car
j'ai une question de fond qui voulez
vous demander est ce que la défiance
envers le vaccin en guadeloupe n'est pas
finalement lié à la défiance envers la
métropole de base je pense qu'il ya un
peu de ça aussi je pense que globalement
dans notre pays et en métropole et dans
les outre-mers la parole publique est un
peu un peu dévalorisés depuis plusieurs
années donc c'est clair que ça s'appuie
aussi là dessus le rapport avec les
médias métropole et sans doute aussi
présents est ce qu'ils se sentent
vraiment respecté de nos concitoyens et
concitoyennes de guadeloupe martinique
et des outre-mer entendu s qui a pas un
ressenti une forme de mépris par rapport
à ce pouvoir central qui est ressenti
des gens métropole france on se souvient
de l'épisode des gilets jaunes qui
étaient un peu à certains égards de même
nature vous fait un parallèle entre le
mouvement des jeunes et le mouvement de
protestation pense il ya des gars des
points communs forcée voilà c'est une
forme de révolte qui s'exprime là bas de
manière plus accrue plus violente encore
mais les questions de fond je pense sont
les mêmes les inégalités les injustices
et puis une forme de mépris peut-être à
l'endroit de ces deux faits département
car cogné homme vous parlez de confiance
car quoniam vous demande comment
regagner la confiance de l'autre mère
après le scandale sanitaire comme la
chlordécone on se souvient de ce donc
c'est un insecticide si je dis oui
considérablement polluer la nappe
phréatique et les sous sols du nouveau
camp des cancers dans la population
c'est un scandale sanitaire absolument
qui a probablement beaucoup lui aussi
entaché la confiance des populations so
lu ment parce que je me suis quand même
que les américains avaient déjà interdit
l'utilisation de ce produit dans leur
production propre et dans les
territoires d'outre-mer chez nous ça a
été maintenu plusieurs années avec des
conséquences fectivement sanitaires
graves sur la vie des gens les l'état de
santé de nos concitoyens
oui c'est sûr que c'est un coup vos
portes et à la confiance de la
population vis-à-vis du pouvoir central
entre guillemets ya bz qui vous
demandez-vous alors au parti communiste
quelles sont vos propositions pour
répondre aux inégalités que subit
l'outre-mer
là on a justement notre candidat fabien
roussel est en déplacement il est parti
en guyane
lundi il est là c'est en guyane de ces
jours ci il est il a prévu de se rendre
en guadeloupe martinique là j'espère que
les circonstances lui permettront d'y
aller mais voilà c'est d'abord une
écoute qu'il faut et puis apporter des
moyens effectivement en matière
d'éducation en matière sanitaire enfin
les problèmes vécus en métropole sont
certainement décuplé dans les
territoires d'outre-mer donc c'est les
mêmes réponses il ya des moyens
financiers il ya une écoute et des
politiques
favorables l égalité sociale dans ces
territoires qui sont largement pénalisés
aujourd'hui il ya quelqu'un qui demande
mais les gan qui demandent si la tournée
de fabien roussel dans les territoires
d'outre-mer étaient planifiés ou est ce
qu'il y aller au vu de la situation
tendue crois que c'est un peu des deux
s'ils avaient prénom elle et elle était
planifiée elle était beau là il a
commencé ses déplacements dans dans
toutes les régions de france mais se
taire et ce déplacement était prévu
effectivement il n'a pas été déclenchée
par par ce qui est en train de se passer
en guadeloupe et martinique est-ce que
vous pensez que la question de la
situation dans les outre mers va être
central dans le débat présidentiel
central je ne sais pas l'avenir nous le
dira mais en tout cas c'est une
illustration de plus de 2 de notre
société fracturée au fond et le
quinquennat qui s'achève malheureusement
comme les précédents n'a pas amélioré
les choses notre société profondément
fracturé alors il n'y a pas forcément là
bas la colère en train de s'exprimer de
manière très violente
c'est pas forcément vrai en france mais
il ya eu l'épisode gilet jaune quand
même mais on sent que ça bouillonne il
ya beaucoup de mal être chez beaucoup de
gens
il ya quelque chose qui tourne pas rond
c'est pas vraiment exprimé
sa cette mort a peut-être d'une manière
spectaculaire et inattendue aux
présidentielles je ne sais pas je ne
suis pas devin mais il ya beaucoup de
non dits dans notre pays aujourd'hui
mais société vraiment fracturé en
profondeur au cours de la séance des
questions au gouvernement sébastien
lecornu le ministre d outre mer a tenu à
réaffirmer que la loi notamment sur
l'obligation vaccinale devait
s'appliquer partout sur le territoire
dans tous les départements y compris
dans les départements d'outre-mer il
oppose le modèle républicain centralisé
à un modèle d'autonomie des territoires
votre position est elle la même moi je
suis pas opposé à ce qu'il y a une
autonomie d'une prise en compte
particulière de la spécificité de ces
territoires compris sur des questions
sanitaires y compris sur les questions
sanitaires voilà encore une fois
écoutons écoutons ce qui se passe que
disent les professions médicales là-bas
enfin il ya besoin de je suis pas un
spécialiste de l'outre-mer je vais pas
me poser en donneur de leçons mais il ya
besoin de comprendre la spécificité mais
je ne suis pas du tout hostile à l'idée
qu'on puisse résonner l'abako
différemment de ce qui se pratique dans
notre métropole voilà il ya des
spécificités sont les territoires
particulier avec une histoire
particulière et une situation encore une
fois économique et social particulier
dernière question sur les questions
d'outre-mer mais plus dans les antilles
cette fois-ci de l'autre côté de la
planète dans le pacifique avec la
nouvelle calédonie qui va voter le 12
décembre prochain pour son troisième
référendum d'autodétermination
référendum qui a priori devrait être
boycotté par les partisans de
l'indépendance on a beaucoup entendu
notamment les candidats au party les
républicains s'exprimer sur ce sujet en
souhaitant que la nouvelle calédonie
reste française on a peu entendu les
communistes parler de ce sujet là qu'est
ce que vous souhaitez pour ce référendum
alors référendum c'est donner la voix
aux peuples sas est souverain mais
j'entends effectivement des inquiétudes
qui s'expriment
par rapport à ce qui pourrait se passer
et là aussi les tensions au sein de la
population en nouvelle calédonie c'est
quand même un territoire stratégique
dans cette partie du monde la zone
pacifique avec l' influence de
l'australie de la chine tout ça n'est
pas étranger à ce contexte géopolitique
c'est pas anodin quoi c'est sûr que il
faut d'abord l'expression d'un peuple et
qu'il faudra respecter quel que soit le
choix qui sera fait et dans l'intérêt
des calédoniens de rester français c'est
à eux de le dire c'est parmi eux de
décider pour l'heure place à la cu qui
le diront comment ils voient leur avenir
on va parler de vous éric bocquet on va
parler de vous et de vos positionnements
politiques c'est parti pour le moment
portrait
éric bocquet vous étiez déjà venu dans
cette émission il ya maintenant un an et
demi on en parlait hors antenne c'était
avant la crise du coc vide il s'est
passé beaucoup de choses depuis on avait
déjà eu l'occasion de parler avec vous
de votre parcours personnel vous pouvez
retrouver sur le site de public sénat
publicsenat.fr le replay de cette
émission j'ai quand même quelques
questions pour vous notamment l'udc qui
vous demandent une question un peu
personnel votre orientation pour le
communisme est ce que ça vient d'une
culture familiale où ça vient d'un
cheminement personnel ça vient pas d'une
culture familiale mais met pas en nos
parents que mon frère lui aussi son
parcours dense dans ce parti politique
c'est pas un héritage familial on n'en
parlait jamais chez nous et pas de
politique à table jamais je n'ai jamais
su ce que même ma mère et mon père voter
on ne
se disait pas pourquoi j'en sais pas ce
que pourtant il ya des familles
communiste de mûron vis des traditions
familiales s'était pas votre classe mk
c'est pas le cas mon père était ouvrier
dans williams a bien travaillé par un
milieu modeste voilà c'était page abidal
milieu modeste mais pas d'engagement
voilà mon frère s'est engagé très tôt
dès qu'il a eu la majorité enfin même 16
17 ans 18 ans il s'est engagé et puis
voilà moi j'étais enseignant pendant 30
ans jusqu'en 2010 mais je me suis engagé
à l'âge de 18 ans au parti communiste
qu'est ce qui vous a attiré dans le
communisme c'était si je me permets tu
sais dans quelle année j'ai adhéré au
parti communiste français en 1975 oui on
est dans les années 70 son amant partie
avant le 22e congrès c'est dire que dans
les statuts du parti communiste français
à l'époque il y avait encore la notion
de dictature du prolétariat jean charest
s'est pas là dessus cette base là que
j'ai adhéré mais quand j'ai adhéré au pc
voilà j'ai cédé encore soviétique en
était encore dans l'alignement à moscou
à ce moment là il y avait eu des pas en
avant il y avait eu des modifications
la condamnation de l'invasion
en tchécoslovaquie par les russes et
soviétiques à l'époque a été condamnée
par le parti communiste français ça n'a
pas été assez dit ça nous a valu des
réprimandes du grand frère moscovite
mais c'était la première fois que nous
marquions
clairement notre désapprobation de cette
pratique savait pas été le cas en 56 en
hongrie par donc 68 ça a marqué un
tournant alors on n'était pas encore
sortie de le monde était pas celui
d'aujourd'hui quoi c'était encore le
bloc de l'est les pays socialistes voilà
non même si c'est difficile je pense que
j difficile pour des jeunes qui écoutent
de se remettre dans l'ambiance de
l'époque pourquoi avoir été séduit par
le parti communiste et pas par un
trotskiste qui était très vivace à
l'époque aussi chez les jeunes oui mais
bon le moteur essentiel de mon
engagement c'est le refus d'injustice et
le refus de la fatalité
marco le gaulois voulez vous demander
quelle est la pertinence du logiciel de
pensée communiste dans le monde moderne
où la de plus en plus pertinents
et au sortir de cette pandémie voyez
vous
on a entendu de beaux discours où mon
premier confinement y compris du
président de la république qui se
remettaient en question dans ses propos
nous allons devoir réfléchir un autre
monde le monde d'après le monde d'après
c'est le monde d'avant empire
quand je vois quand je vois le joaillier
cette année dans le magazine challenges
chaque année publie le palmarès des 500
premières fortunes de france là c'est
pas une marotte mais c'est ainsi
le soutien du titre une année record en
pleine année qu vide alors on s'est dit
mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire l'économie du monde s'est
arrêté pendant deux mois a été fortement
ralentie pendant l'année et encore
aujourd'hui on n'est pas encore revenu à
100% et pendant cette période là le
l'argent continue à se développer les
dividendes prospère on bat les records
et puis aujourd'hui le bilan est là les
restaurants du coeur viennent d'ouvrir
leur 37e campagne ça devait durer un ou
deux
il ya du chômage et des difficultés il
ya la désespérance 9 millions de gens
sous le seuil de pauvreté un million de
plus de 1 million d'allocataires du rsa
en plus les départements pris à la gorge
voilà on a une société encore plus
clivée qu'elle ne l'était avant la
pandémie donc oui
communisme c'est le mot c'est le mot en
commun voyez c'est le concret une
richesse le monde entier l'humanité
complète créés chaque année 80 mille
milliards de dollars sont des chiffres
qui dépassent une vie humaine mais ça la
richesse du monde voilà et comme on peut
accepter dans un pays comme le nôtre
cinquième sixième puissance du monde on
arrive à des situations aussi
dramatiques sans tomber dans le
catastrophisme ce pays c'est société
encore une fois est fracturée donc oui
la mise en commun de cette richesse
c'est à dire il faut alors jérémy
dernière c'est pas ça le sujet mais que
la richesse doit revenir à tout le monde
vous comprenez que dans la question de
marco il ya aussi la question de
peut-être du tempo on en parlait tout à
l'heure les années soixante dix urss
depuis la chute du mur de berlin le
monde a beaucoup changé
ça doit pas être facile pour un parti
comme le parti communiste de continuer à
justifier son existence et son logiciel
à travers ces âges et pourtant vous y
arrivez
s'assume pleinement j'assume pleinement
notre histoire j'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure avec ses erreurs avec ses
réussites avec la contribution qu'on
n'ait pu apporter à l'histoire de france
pas seul voilà front populaire la
résistance la lutte anti coloniale et
ses programmes comme un programme commun
qui a été le choix stratégique de
l'époque voilà mais non non moi je sais
pour en direct on a voulu faire croire
que le parti communiste français allait
être enterrée sous les décombres du mur
de berlin effectivement 89 et ben non
c'est pas ça qui s'est passé alors on a
traversé une période difficile l'un aux
assume mais on s'est battu on a des élus
on a un groupe à l'assemblée un groupe
au sénat on a des mères on a des élus un
peu partout on a une organisation qui
s'est affaiblie mais on est encore là on
est capable d'organiser une fête de
l'humanité au mois de septembre dans un
contexte compliqué avec un certain
succès mais c'est pas c'est pas un
succès commercial c'est devenu une
certaine capacité à rassembler des gens
qui pensent pas comme nous voilà vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure vous avez été
prof d'anglais pendant trente ans
une question de drake qui voulez-vous
demander qu'est ce que vous pensez des
démissions dans l'éducation nationale
qui ont été rendus publics récemment des
profs qui ont décidé de quitter
le ministère comment rendre le métier
plus attractif c'était sa question
absolument et même dans les concours de
recrutement tous les postes sont pas
pourvus quoi on ne sait pas si son poste
et on prend qu'à 150 enseignants parce
que c'est trop au niveau du recrutement
non le métier n'est plus attractifs
l'est ma fille est principale adjointe
du collège depuis et alors ça a changé
depuis notre époque voilà elle était
prof d'anglais comme moi n'y a aucun
atavisme c'est ainsi elle a choisi ce
métier
elle a commencé son métier il ya dix ans
à 1400 euros par mois et à l'époque elle
était affectée en région parisienne elle
avait un loyer de 750 euros donc elle
rentrait week end les maisons devront
partir de la nourriture et un chèque
voilà je le dit et je cite souvent son
cas moi quand j'ai commencé
l'enseignement dans les années en 1981
exactement le salaire de l'enseignant
moyen c'était deux fois le smic ok
d'accord aujourd'hui c'est 1,4 fois le
smic il ya eu un décrochage niveau du
salaire alors le salaire ce n'est pas
tout on va pas tout régler que ça mais
quand même la reconnaissance d'un métier
difficile dans des classes où se
rassemblent tous les problèmes de la
société 1 les inégalités la pauvreté
l'illettrisme le harcèlement la violence
1 les gamins aujourd'hui sont confrontés
à des situations quand même extrêmement
difficile l'effet des réseaux sociaux
pas forcément contrôler c'est un sujet
je ne peux pas imaginer que ça ne
perturbe pas le fonctionnement d'un
groupe classe voilà donc le métier très
difficile et c'est un métier magnifique
l'école de la république va j'ai
toujours cru à ça moi je j'ai été formé
par l'école et mon parti je sais mais de
gens moi y est ça donc l'école c'est il
faut la chérir et aujourd'hui oui un mal
être profond chez les enseignants et on
peut que ce s'inquiéter de ces
démissions déjà ont recruté plus
beaucoup et ceux qui sont en place après
dix quinze ans de carrière veulent faire
autre chose et tu partes c'est très
c'est très grave ce qui se passe il est
urgent de répondre à ça il ya l'omi qui
voulez vous demandez vous en avez parlé
du harcèlement suite au terrible suicide
qu'on a appris de la part d'adolescents
victimes de harcèlement sco 1 est ce que
vous sentez que la situation a changé
depuis l'époque où vous étiez prof
d'anglais est ce que vous pensez que la
réponse du gouvernement est à la hauteur
vous voyez ce problème c'est sûr c'est
un problème nouveau je vais arrêter
d'enseignement en 2010 il n'y avait pas
c'est pas le moyen âge c'est pas la
préhistoire 2010 mais il n'y avait pas
une telle prégnance des réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui tous les gamins à partir de
8 9 ans ils ont dans la poche et dans la
main en permanence la connexion
connectés en temps réel y compris
pendant les coups ça a changé des choses
ça pour vince existait déjà le
harcèlement scolaire c'est pas nouveau
comme le harcèlement mais oui un peu la
tête de turc elle et qui en prenait plus
que les autres oui ça a toujours existé
mais aujourd'hui s'est décuplée que
c'est plus violents on a des amis là qui
qui ont été confrontés à ça avec leur
fille adolescente de 14 ans ça fait peur
ils ont ils ont découvert la réalité du
problème voilà tout le monde découvre ça
il faut une vraie réponse là il faut des
psychologues aussi dans l'établissement
scolaire des psychologues des médecins
des adultes référents acquis un jeune
peut se confier parce que la relation
prof élève c'est pas si simple je ne
pense pas qu'un spontanément un élèves
dans une classe ira voir son prof la
relation n'est pas la même gouvernement
al'intention de responsabiliser les
élèves de faire des élèves ambassadeurs
qui vont pouvoir rejoindre loin
d'ailleurs pourquoi pas il faut inventer
les choses il faut vraiment répondre de
manière offensive à cette question parce
que vraiment ça fait des dégâts quoi on
est en pleine campagne présidentielle
éric bocquet ça agite beaucoup les les
neurones de beaucoup d'internautes qui
m'ont posé plein de questions pour vous
une question de colin très simple
comment est-ce que vous appréhendez
cette campagne qui commence vous
soutenez fabien roussel on le disait
tout à l'heure je sais comment vous la
voyez cette campagne
aujourd'hui on parle pas des sujets qui
préoccupent les français enfin on voit
comment ça a démarré
quand je vois ce qui se passe dans la
non pas la primaire mais le congrès des
républicains les cinq candidats
passage obligé dans les débats deux
tiers du temps immigration sécurité
identité nationale
islam
très inquiétant il ya ça il ya zemmour
et les gens dans la rue moi il me parle
de pouvoir d'achat d'ailleurs c'est le
revenu intéressant vous parler
spontanément des candidats de droite la
gauche est inaudible la gauche et est
faible globalement le cumul des
candidats de gauche on est à 24 25 26 %
ça fait pas la main ils s'éclairent 1
mais c'est l'ensemble de la gauche qui
est affaiblie aujourd'hui moi je me
félicite que il ya un candidat pas par
esprit de chapelle issu de nos rangs
n'aurait apparaissons en plus il fait
froid qu'il fait une campagne
intéressante ça va pas tout régler il
faudra aussi une cape une campagne
militante faudra voilà faux faux du
monde c'est pas à la faire d'un individu
aussi aussi performant soit il c'est
profond et puis redonner la confiance
aux gens parce que le quinquennat
hollande a fait du mal à l'idée même de
gauche je pense le déplore je me réjouis
pas mais l'idée même de gauche a pris et
a pris des coups terribles après ce
quinquennat de renoncement y compris le
candidat qui a renoncé à se présenter au
renouvellement enfin vous regretté
françois hollande ne se soit pas
présenté à sarceaux sessions de jeu je
regrette pas c'était la fin d'un
quinquennat désastreux voilà on est
passé de mon adversaire c'est le monde
de la finance le 20 janvier 2012 au
bourget discours magnifique que je peux
signer dès demain à au renoncement à sa
candidature en décembre 2007 voyez on le
dégâts que ça fait quoi dans l'opinion
donc oui la gauche est en difficulté
mais les problèmes sont là il ya des
propositions qui sont formulées voilà il
appartiendra aux gens de deux tranches
et de redonner de la force à l'ensemble
d'une force alternative progressiste
pour dépasser ce système il ya d'aunis
qui veut vous demander ce que vous
croyez à une union de la gauche de
gauche pour la présidentielle
aujourd'hui je ne la vois pas je ne la
sens pas parce qu'elle est différence
voilà aujourd'hui c'est les différences
insurmontables éric bocquet
disons le clairement le parti communiste
et la france en sont ils ont été alliés
au cours des deux derniers scrutins
présidentielle il se trouve que là vous
l'avez dit vous-même pas par esprit de
chapelle certes mais fabien roussel a
décidé de maintenir sa candidature
il ya aussi les écologistes autour de
yannick jadot il ya le parti socialiste
avec anne hidalgo est ce que les
différences entre ces quatre candidats
sont insurmontables au point d'empêcher
le fait de semaine d'accord il ya il ya
des différences majeures sur la proche
par rapport à l'énergie nucléaire c'est
un bon exemple c'est fondamental fabien
roussel a réaffirmé clairement et je
pense qu'il a bien fait la nécessité de
développer cette énergie parce que elle
et pas cher elle est décarbonée elle est
pilotable bon ce qui n'empêche kabyle
faille en même temps avancé sur le la
multiplicité des sources d'énergie parce
que de l'énergie va en falloir de plus
en plus donc c'est un choix du nucléaire
n'a pas empêché les socialistes et les
écolos de marcher ensemble en 2012 par
exemple alors qu'on sait que ce n'était
pas toujours d'accord dans se trouver un
compromis mais on peut faire des
compromis à gauche encore aujourd'hui ou
severo comment dirais-je se rassembler
sur quoi cc c'est le projet qui doit
être fédérateur aujourd'hui le lie à des
projets différents france insoumise et
je n'attaque personne disant cela on a
des différences aussi a vécu enfin il
faut s'appuyer sur les gens redonner
confiance c'est pas par esprit de
chapelle que voilà chacun et puis il ya
deux tours quoi il ya un premier tour où
chacun a le droit de figurer et doit
figurer parce que pour échapper à un
débat justement contre un on nous
imposerait des thèmes à la cie skate 2
du style les prénoms et c'est
franchement c'est pas ça le sujet le
sujet c'est quelle société on veut
demain est ce qu on a l'argent pour
financer nos services publics est-ce qu
on vit au dessus de nos moyens c'est ce
qu'on nous raconte depuis 40 ans je ne
crois pas un instant mais tous figurer
au premier tour est ce que ce n'est pas
le meilleur moyen de se retrouver avec
une union derrière emmanuel macron au
second tour par défaut aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est ce que les sondages
semblent nous dire mais bon on a appris
ce défi les sondages et puis voyant là
une campagne et puis aller au débat avec
les gens partout des quartiers alors je
vais vous aider sur un sujet qui peut
aussi être un sujet clivant à gauche
c'est la question du travail
à stalingrad place stalingrad à paris
fabien roussel a dénoncé ceux qui à
gauche théorise la fin du travail il a
dit je cite ce n'est pas ma gauche la
mienne elle croit au travail aux
salaires les salariés ne veulent pas
d'allocations ils veulent s'épanouir au
travail est ce qu'il ya une différence
insurmontable sur la relation à la
valeur travail entre la france insoumise
et et le parti communiste
avec la france un semis je ne sais pas
mais on entend des discours depuis
quelques temps depuis quelques années
c'est benoît hamon qui portait cette
idée d'un revenu universel alors éric
bocquet vous en pensez quoi du revenu
universel non les gens veulent vivre
dignement de leur travail d'abord ils
veulent avoir du boulot
en étant respectés dans leurs conditions
de travail dans leur responsabilité dans
le temps de travail dans leur salle est
à bien évidemment on nous dit parfois on
a du mal à recruter dans certains
secteurs mais c'est quoi le salaire
c'est quoi les conditions de travail il
faut regarder l'ensemble non moi je on
n'est pas la fin de l'histoire on n'est
pas à la fin du travail n'ont plus cessé
le travail qui crée la richesse c'est
pas les milliards des laudes moche que
quand il annonce que le loueur de
voitures hertz va acheter 100 mille
voitures et véhicules tesla son action
en bourse a explosé il a gagné une
journée 36 milliards ça c'est pas du
travail ça c'est la spéculation c'est
l'argent pour l'argent moi je crois à la
valeur travail c'est pas ringard mais le
travail moderniser adapté et puis et
puis qui répondent aux besoins des gens
croient qu'ils répondent aux besoins de
l'économie réelle c'est intéressant ce
que là aussi on sent justement à gauche
qui est un sujet autour de cette
question là quand vous voyez d'ailleurs
le président de la république emmanuel
macron réaffirmé lui aussi son amour du
travail il a redit dans son allocution à
la télévision le travail le travail la
france au travail vous rejoignez une
voilà une logique de valorisation du
travail pour ce qu'il est oui mais
problème c'est que le travail il aurait
fallu le défendre à howard poule à
amiens voyait il faut être vigilant par
rapport à ce qui se passe à ce qu'au val
à saint saulve dans mon département ou
des engagements sont pris et que l'on
voit bien que les actionnaires les
financiers ont une autre vision des
choses court termiste et rentabilité
financière à deux chiffres revoyez donc
le travail c'est ça c'est l'outil de
travail aussi si on parle de relocaliser
les productions le travail doit être au
coeur de ça donc ça veut dire aussi les
formations les qualifications qui font
aussi partie d'un contrat cae avec eux
avec l'ensemble des salariés de ce pays
télagh voulez vous demander que pensez
vous des déclarations de ministres qui
s'opposent à la culture moque je cite on
pense notamment jean michel blanquer air
qui a dénoncé leur autisme oui alors oui
logo qui ça c'est encore un méta débat
là qui surgit tout lac ou moi je moi je
suis pour que tous les opprimés du monde
se rassemblent oui parce que bien sûr
qu'il faut être conscient des
discriminations contre telle ou telle
corporation catégorie de gens etc mais
tout ça c'est les opprimés d'un même
système je vais pas plage et karl marx
mais vous pouvez imprimer de tous les
pays unissez vous voyez c'est ça c'est
le manifeste du 21e siècle c'est ça le
vrai sujet le ce qu'on appelle mots
qu'ils veulent avoir conscience des
discriminations à l'endroit de telle ou
telle catégorie de personnes oui c'est
une réalité mais tout ça découle d'un
système où l'exploitation et la règle
global fois l'introduction du pronom
yale dont le dictionnaire annoncé par le
petit robert qui a fait réagir jusqu'au
gouvernement jusqu'à la première dame
elle même ça aussi c'est un non débat
pour vous pour moi c'est un non débat
comment on fait pour accorder yale est
beau ou yelle est belle je ne pose la
question j'ai enseigné le français aussi
dans la vie je ne pose la question de
l'accord par rapport à quel pro non je
dis ça en plaisantant mais c'est pas
c'est un débat central ce qui est
central oui lutter contre les
discriminations
la liberté de choix du genre oui mais
franchement aller jusqu au langage je
suis très sceptique sur l'utilité d'un
tel débat ça c'était une question d'
edgar 52 et il ya françois qui
voulez-vous demander est-ce que vous
retireriez les statuts de colbert par
référence à rama yade ancien ministre à
l'époque de nicolas sarkozy qui a
déclaré que sont elles passées dans les
statuts le colbert quand on est noir
c'est une micro agression en référence
au code noir qui a été promulguée par
colbert il faut avoir conscience de ce
que l'histoire de france a fait de mal
clairement mais de la débaptiser à
démolir des statuts voilà il faut
appréhender notre histoire avec ses
zones d'ombré ces zones de lumière voilà
les le code noir c'était une infamie
absolue voilà c'est l'histoire il faut
l'avoir en tête faut la connaître mais
s'amuser à débaptiser ben voilà il va
falloir
il ya du boulot au coin de mise à jour
en faire pour nettoyer l'histoire de
france de ses pires exactions et quand
vous entendez vous m'avez dit tout à
l'heure que vous regardiez le débat des
congrès les républicains quand vous
entendez tous les candidats dire qu'il
faut être fier de l'ensemble de
l'histoire de france qu'il faut
valoriser l'histoire de france et la
prendre comme un bloc vous êtes en
désaccord avec ça a complètement oui
enfin il faut connaître l'histoire de
france mais l'histoire de france n'est
pas linéaire on a des zones sombres de
notre histoire
vichy que certains veulent réhabiliter
dans le débat politique c'est non c'est
un scandale le la guerre d'algérie c'est
pas c'est pas une chose dont on peut
être fier quoi le massacre des algériens
en octobre 61 à paris il faut clarifier
sa fin non il faut regarder l'histoire
d'adam dans sa diversité
sans rien d'occulté mais voyez les
choses dont je suis pas fier dans cette
histoire de ce point de vue là est ce qu
emmanuel macron avec le rapport stora
avec le travail qu'il a fait notamment
sur le taux de 61 avec la mémoire des
harkis également est ce que vous trouvez
qu'il va dans le bon sens ce sont des
mesures qui vont dans le bon sens avec
odin là le mathématicien comme lis
tu es à l'époque on ne regarde algérie
voilà ça ce sont des ddd pas qu'ils vont
dans le bon sens voilà je le dis en
toute objectivité
vous êtes sénateur du nord je le disais
tout à l'heure wortel voulez-vous
demander malgré la réélection au premier
tour de xavier bertrand lors des
élections régionales peut-on encore
considérer le nord comme une terre de
gauche
soit une histoire mais oui il fallait il
ya des il ya des valeurs auxquelles nous
sommes attachés mais comme toute la
société on a essayé était traversé par
des périodes très difficiles la
désindustrialisation enfin il ya une
perte de repères de conscience et oui
c'est sûr que l'abstention a grandi
comme partout que le
front national à l'époque rassemble
nationale aujourd'hui a grandi sur ces
territoires en déshérence abandonné
après moi j'ai toujours été un peu
sceptique sur l'idée de terre de gauche
ou terre de droite ya pas de passion jeu
je crois plus à des combats menés
localement et un cliché de dire le nord
est de gauche et les alpes maritimes
sont droite c'est un peu claires
oui je crois je crois qu'il ya lieu de
toutes les forces avec des dosages
différents dans toutes les régions de
france donc là ne sont bastien je suis
très réservé et donc oui on a une
histoire à gauche dans nord pas de
calais c'est clair une terre ouvrière
mais je vous ai volumes et les racines
sont là toujours sur la sur le sur le
sur le nord est fragile voulez vous
demander votre point de vue sur le
projet d'installation d'un parc éolien
offshore dans la manche d'être favorable
au développement de l'éolien
favorable au développement de l'éolien
s'il ne nuit pas s'il ne cause pas de
nuisances à ça fait partie du mix
énergétique entre le sujet et là en fait
est ce que ça cause des mises en
pratique du mix et des mix énergétique
que après j'entends que ça provoque des
perturbations sur les
l'activité halieutique la pêche et
perturbé on a des amis en normandie qui
sont opposés à un projet de ce type donc
voilà j'ai pas une position définitive
arrêtée là dessus l'éolien ça fait
partie des options du mix énergétique
avec le solaire
voilà l'hydrogène demain enfin voilà il
ya des choses à creuser faut que la
science avance
mais j'ai pas de position arrêtée très
clairement sur le sujet aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui vous êtes sénateur eric
bocquet on va parler de votre activité
au sénat c'est parti pour le moment
sénat
une question de diop qui vous demandent
comment concevez vous votre mandat
d'homme de gauche dans une assemblée
historiquement acquise à la droite même
pas rien d'être communiste au sénat non
mais ça se passe pas mal à expliquer moi
alors c'est vrai ce soit sinon mais êtes
minoritaires oui on est très minoritaire
on est un petit groupe 15 dès qu'un
sénateur soutient voilà on est quinze
ans groupe fayat 14 communiste et une
rattachés marie noëlle lienemann en
l'occurrence mais ça se passe très bien
c'est un groupe qui travaille beaucoup
enfin reconnu pour ça je préfère
l'autosatisfaction ses palais tout genre
de la maison
oui c'est sûr que on est 15 dans une
assemblée 340 7 sénateurs mais voilà on
porte notre discours on a de la
constance on a de l'énergie on a de la
conviction
non on ne souffre pas d'être minoritaire
nous travaillons à devenir majoritaire
ya grill dans le chat qui demande c'est
quoi ces airs cecr c'est le nom du
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes qui est le nom du groupe
communiste c'est comme ça que l'appel
pour simplifier au sénat ça que c'est
pas simple d'expliquer autre attaque à
chaque fois les sigles voit la crc veut
en gros c'est le groupe communiste au
sénat dont les membres m'ont invité éric
bocquet voilà pour la réponse à ta
question il y avait une autre question
qui était celle de tsp garp qui vous
demandent pourquoi avoir choisi de
rester sénateurs plutôt que mr en 2017
en application du non cumul des mandats
j'étais maire j'étais maire quatre
mandats
c'est un mandat passionnante je n'ai pas
quitté le mandat de maire
comment dirais-je en applaudissant mais
voilà c'est l'application de la loi je
suis reparti de du conseil municipal je
suis conseiller municipal dans dans ce
collectif c'est un collègue qui est
devenue mère voilà oui j'aurais pu
choisir de rester de rester maire vous
sentez plus utile au sénat qu'en tant
que mère comme ça non c'est pas
comparable j'ai dit c'est sûr que dans
une mairie l'intérêt c'est que vous
voyez aboutir les projets que vous
lancez avec votre équipe voilà en bref
voilà c'est du travail c'est du temps
c'est dû délaisser des complications
mais au bout ça aboutit quoi quand vous
construisez un lotissement un foyer de
vie pour des personnes handicapées au
restaurant scolaire
c'est concret c'est utile et dont c'est
vraiment passionnant c'est vraiment un
mandat passionnant mais le sénat c'est
une autre dimension et
c'est une expérience qui enrichissante
éric bocquet vous avez une spécialité si
je puis dire en tant que sénateur vous
êtes spécialité spécialistes pardon des
questions budgétaires et notamment
fiscales vous avez travaillé toute notre
vie sur la question de la lutte contre
la fraude fiscale contre l'évasion
fiscale
et vivien vous demande simplement
pourquoi avoir choisi la politique
fiscale et la fraude fiscale comme sujet
de prédilection comment ça c'est fait ça
commence assez faible est prof d'anglais
ses data service fiscal ce n'est pas
évident lorsque l'anglais dans le monde
de la finance ça sert parce que c'est la
logique et la langue anglo saxon qui
dominent le monde de la finance et
récent c'est vrai mais c'est pas ça la
motivation en fait j'ai été élu en 2011
je me suis retrouvé rapporta d'une
commission d' enquête en janvier 2012
quelques mois plus tard je sais même pas
ce que c'était une police une enquête
le rapporteur ok je vais être l'occasion
de nous rappeler ce que c'est parce
qu'il ya plein de safa savoir la
commission denquête c'est un groupe de
25 26 sénateurs rassemblant toutes les
sensibilités de l'hémicycle à proportion
de ce que chacun paye et chaque groupe
politique chaque année peut proposer la
création d'une commission d' enquête sur
un sujet donné et cette année là il se
trouve qu'on avait choisi le la lutte
contre l'évasion fiscale fraude fiscale
et c est donc comme c'est la proposition
venait de notre groupe communistes
républicains citoyens écologistes la
fonction du rapporteur un combat un
représentant de ce groupe c'est comme ça
que je me suis trouvé rapporteur celui
qui est chargé avec l'équipe de rédiger
le rapport qui est rendu à la fin des
travaux donc ces six mois de travaux
c'est des auditions des déplacements à
l'étranger alors on n'est pas allé aux
bahamas aux bermudes cette commission
d'enquêté en 2012 était sur quels sujets
sur l'a7 et lutte contre la fraude
fiscale c'était ça donc un travail
passionnant au début je me demandais ce
qu'on allait faire pendant six mois et
puis à la fin j'ai dit il faut continuer
donc on a fait une deuxième commission
denquête l'année suivante sur le même
sujet et voilà donc on a accumulé 1
cette connaissance de contacts et au
bout du bout ça fait des décennies qu'on
nous explique que la france vit au
dessus de ses moyens on n'a plus les
moyens de financer notre modèle social
le qu'il ya la dette et puis on découvre
que la fraude fiscale chaque année alors
il n'y a pas un chiffre officiel mais la
fourchette c'est de 60 à 100 milliards
d'euros perdus chaque année au titre de
l'évasion fiscale si je prends le
chiffre de 80 milliards
80 milliards c'était le déficit annuel
de l'époque dans le budget voyez vous
alors on va pas régler en appuyant sur
un bouton le déficit mais un enjeu de
fond
consistait à mener une lutte acharnée
résolu internationales contre la fraude
fiscale et l'évasion qui nous coûtent
des centaines de milliards d'euros je
précise que vous aviez que vous avez
écrit avec votre frère alain bocquet ce
livre milliards en fuite un plaidoyer un
manifeste pour une finance éthique que
vous avez sorti cette année aux éditions
du cherche midi vous aviez par le passé
également écrit sans domicile fisc à
nouveau un livre sur la question de la
fraude fiscale ce qui voit là fait de
vous un sénateur spécialiste de cette
question là vous avez vu comme nous tous
les révélations de consortiums de
journalistes ces derniers temps sur des
systèmes mondialisée organisé de fraude
fiscale et d'évasion fiscale dans le
monde entier vous n'avez pas
l'impression de perdre la bataille non
non parce que parce que l'enjeu de fond
et là il ya de la ressource il ya de
l'argent il faut aller le chercher mais
il faut une volonté politique et cette
volonté politique faut la faire monter
dans l'opinion mais le problème c'est
que l'opinion s'en occupe voyez vous
citiez des révélations l'aller pandora
paper
qui sait encore ce que c'est aujourd'hui
c'était un mois ces révélations au moins
sévrier il ya eu open luxe au public sa
durée de trois jours cinquante cinq
mille sociétés off shore au luxembourg
qui détiennent 6500 milliards d'actifs
luxembourg c'est 300 kilomètres d'ici
c'est l'union européenne c'est au coeur
de l'union européenne les pandora paper
on a vu les les chiffres absolument
hallucinant qui dépasse la vie humaine
onze mille 300 milliards de dollars
disséminés dans les paradis fiscaux dans
le monde voilà s'il n'y a pas un sujet
là dessus franchement
il y aurait de quoi financer des
hôpitaux des écoles des routes des
collectivités un monde meilleur quoi
donc elle est là ma motivation arrêtez
de dire qu'il ya pas d'argent il ya de
l'argent mais ils échappent aux états
en parlant d'argent le sénat vient
d'examiner ou plutôt de finir l'examen
du budget dans du projet de loi de
finances pour 2022 le sénat a rejeté le
budget on arrête d'en discuter puisque
le sénat a rejeté le volet recettes
pourrait nous expliquer parce que c'est
pas simple pour nous comment ça se fait
que le sénat a rejeté le volet recettes
du budget et que donc la discussion
s'arrête là alors oui c'est lui qui nous
en fait ce qu'on appelle la première
partie d'une loi de finances d'un budget
pour parler simple c'est les recettes
donc on vote les impôts on vote les taux
de tva enfin voyez tout ce qui est axe
qui va alimenter le budget de l'état
donc avant d'engager des dépenses dans
la deuxième partie sur la défense la
culture l'éducation la santé etc il faut
d'abord voté les recettes or la
constitution dit et c'est logique que si
la première partie n'est pas voté la
discussion budgétaire s'arrête puisque
on n'a pas voté les recettes on peut pas
décemment laisser des dépenses ouais
c'est une question de cohérence alors là
effectivement on est confronté à cette
situation c'est le dernier budget du
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron on
approche des échéances dont on a parlé
présidentielle évidemment ça a perturbé
singulièrement les choses et ça a
surtout généré des postures chez les
républicains on leur a dit dans le débat
très respectueusement on assister à des
mouvements à l'uci dans il y avait 600
amendements à discuter à partir de
vendredi 16 à briller donc on
s'attendait à siéger vendredi samedi
dimanche et puis la dives et le vote
devait intervenir mardi on démarre à 16
heures et on va jusqu'à 1h30 samedi
matin on avait traité la moitié des
amendements
d'habitude quand on discute des
amendements on en traite 12 15 20 par
heure là on était à 40 à l'heure et
pourquoi parce que les républicains ont
siégé n'ont pas déposé d'amendement et
n'ont pas pris la parole donc c'est la
moitié du temps de débat qui a été gagné
entre guillemets par le silence des
républicains et pourquoi il était
silencieux le républicain lorrain lucien
le la consigne chez eux ce n'est de ne
pas déposer d'amendement parce qu'ils
avaient déjà décidé
de voter contre la première partie leur
décision était prise d'accord il avait
décidé d'essayer ça a été dit à travers
du temps du trafic va pas s'embarrasser
pas d'amendement pas d'intervention et
ça s'est arrêté donc effectivement hier
avec le vote je rappelle que les
républicains c'est le groupe majoritaire
au sénat vous aussi être contre ce
budget présenté par le gouvernement mais
pas pour les raisons absolue en
l'occurrence les républicains et ça a
été expliqué par bruno retailleau le
président du groupe l'est républicain la
tribune a expliqué que ce budget est un
budget démagogues ou le gouvernement
emmanuel macron quasi candidat à la
présidentielle fait campagne avec le
chéquier de la france et donc c'est ça
la contestation par là et puis tiens
vous c'est pas ce que vous reprochez à
ce budget et du coup j'ai une question
de mister magoo ya qui vous demande
qu'est ce qui vous dérange dans ce
budget mais nous on avait proposé les
amendements avaient déposé 80
amendements parmi lesquels ont demandé
le rétablissement de l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune
75% de nos concitoyens sont favorables
cette idée alors c'est pas par démagogie
c'est parce que l'ailier sf rapporté
avant sa suppression 5 milliard 2 voilà
il était remplacé par l'impôt sur la
fortune immobilière qui rapporte
beaucoup moins d'argent donc la roya 3
milliards 2 qu'on a perdu là par la
suppression de l'sf ce que sarkozy
chirac n'a pas n'ont pas osé faire
macron l'a fait oui alors c'est pas avec
ça qu'on va tout régler mais trois ou
quatre milliards symbolique liée cela
c'est un c'est un marqueur politique
faure un président des riches on avait
également déposé des amendements pour
proposer que le fasse qu'on appelle le
prélèvement forfaitaire unique
c'est-à-dire taxation des dividendes
plafonnées à 30% plus de progressivité
ça aussi c'est macron on avait demandé
la suppression du pmu l'amendement a
évidemment été refusée voilà
troisième exemple que je peux donner sur
les taux de tva on avait proposé qu'un
taux de 5 et demi pour cent et le taux
le plus faible soit appliquée aux
quatorze premiers mètres cubes d'eau
consommée par les citoyens un premier
produit de première nécessité évidemment
abonnement retoqué voilà voilà au moins
trois raisons il y en a plein d'autres
pour lesquels on peut pas soutenir ce
budget qui ne répond pas à la crise
sociale que l'on en train de traverser
je fais une parenthèse yade jonas dans
le chat qui dit éric bocquet c'était mon
prof d'anglais au lycée un ancien élève
bonjour là bonjour on revient sur la
question budgétaire
on revient sur la question budgétaire
une question de pro qui pot qui vous
demande quel est votre rapport à la
dette publique
faut-il la résorber faut-il la limite et
comment on fait vis-à-vis de la dette je
vous l'annulez la nuit les carrément je
vais le dire ça veut dire quoi la rue ne
pas les rembourser ses bons précisé ça
fait quelques années que je suis sur lui
peiné par cette histoire de dette sur
les dents quand on a les documents
budgétaires
le remboursement des le paiement des
intérêts de la dette l'an prochain ça va
représenter 38 4 milliards d'euros qu'on
va payer aux marchés financiers qui nous
finance nous allons réemprunter 260
milliards cette année on a emprunté 260
l'an dernier c'est déjà le cas et l'an
prochain on va ré emprunter 263 vous
allez me dire on va pas réussir
emprunter bas si on fait la queue pour
nous prêter l'argent en france ces taux
sont très bas comme on dit ils sont même
négatif sur les sur les emprunts
involontaire l' agence france trésor qui
est le bercy qui vend notre dette sur
les marchés financiers
tous les lundis une adjudication on
emprunte 6 7 9 milliards les taux à
trois mois six mois 12 mois c'est un peu
technique sont situés les tos et - 0 800
-0 6 ans c'est à dire qu'on va emprunter
100 et rembourser 90 ou 95 aux marchés
financiers
moi si j'étais à découvert je vais les
voir mon directeur de banque est ce que
vous pourriez me prêter un peu d'argent
je dois acheter un nouveau véhicule il
va bien et si possible à tous négatifs
essayez fait l'expérience vous allez
voir la réponse dernier en agence nous
donc c'est qu'il ya quelque chose qui va
pas sur cette dette et en plus la dette
est devenue l'argument massue pour
justifier aux yeux des gens la réduction
de la dépense publique
dire qu'il n'ya pas de moyens pour
financer les retraites les hôpitaux les
écoles les routes etc éric bocquet
emprunter à taux négatif c'est pas
éternel on se souvient de pays y compris
européens qui se retrouvait avec des
taux qui se sont envolés à 1 15% des 1 %
c'est la dette ont la rembourse jamais
l'état ce qu on appelle ça s'appelle
rouler la dette dire que les 260
milliards d'euros là qu'on voie
empruntée il y en a cent quarante qui
serviront à rembourser les emprunts
antérieurs arrivée à terre et les
l'autre c'est bien la preuve qu'on
rembourse on rembourse pas le capital
enfin on rembourse le capital des
emprunts arrivé à terme et on réemprunte
ont fait un nouvel emprunt pour
rembourser l'emprunt échu et donc on
rembourse bien avec les intérêts on paie
que les intérêts il ya deux ans c'était
40 milliards là on va rembourser l'an
prochain 38 4 autrement dit le système
est complètement dingue que plus on
emprunte moins on paye on attirait en
intérêts seule monnaie en capital ont
vécu les intérêts en fait c'est comme si
on était chez cofinoga où c'étaient les
mouiller on est dans une espèce de
système de revolving pour le coup les
gens est payant ouais voilà mais là ça
coûte beaucoup plus cher mais nous on
emprunte à taux négatifs on est à 2007
140 milliards de dettes la en 1953 j'ai
découvert ça que je viens de faire un
rapport au sénat sur la dette publique
avec une collègue centriste pour ça que
je pose la question de vie vermeille et
on a fait un travail là dessus chacun
dans nos différences mais d'accord sur
certains constats il faut arrêter le
discours catastrophiste et
culpabilisateur de la dette savait qu'on
allemand le modèle se dit chad
edition c'est la faute aussi en allemand
henkell déguisés mais excusez moi oui
c'est vrai we should cela faut donc
c'est la dette et c'est la faute donc
une dimension culpabilisatrice dans le
mode est tu es endetté tu arrêtes tu es
coupable oui c'est ça paraît ridicule
mais franchement je croise à la dette
c'est l'argument massue pour justifier
la réduction des des budgets de là où il
ya des besoins arrêtons de dire qu'on
vit au dessus de nos moyens pour nom des
thés générations futures c'est pas vrai
c'est pas vrai la maturité de la dette
sein c'est le terme que les techniciens
après ses 8 ans et sept mois dire que si
on arrête d'emprunter dans huit ans et 7
mois on aura fini de de payer nos dettes
oui mais on réemprunte chaque année oui
mais justement c'est pour ça qu'on dit
qu'on a eu pendant qu'on craint que les
gens qui sont pas d'accord avec vous
dise qu'on embête les générations
futures c'est que les 140 milliards
qu'on rembourse chaque année oui c'est
des emprunts qui ont été faits à une
autre époque oui mais pas à une époque
60 ans il ya un mythe en voilà et là on
vient d'emprunter à trois mois six mois
un an il ya l'emprunt qu'on a fait lundi
on veut y en a qu'on va rembourser dans
un employé donc c'est pas une dette qui
remonte à mathusalem non non c'est même
à l'antiquité on parlait le dette et
dans l'antiquité on pouvait être réduit
à l'esclavagé pour non remboursement de
la dette angela merkel emmanuel macron
ont fait adopter par le conseil européen
et par les institutions européennes un
plan de relance à hauteur de 750
milliards d'euros empruntés sur les
marchés financiers par une dette
mutualisée pour le coup pour le dire
vulgairement les pays riches européens
ont emprunté pour les pays pauvres pour
permettre de verser beaucoup d'argent
notamment l'italie et l'espagne
france en touche et 40 milliards à peu
près voilà est-ce que vous êtes
favorable à cette politique d'emprunt il
ya peut-être une piste de ce côté là
parce que ce que faire de la dette alors
quand je dis de manière provocatrice il
faut pas la rembourser vols annulés il
faut annuler on peut annuler
techniquement celle qui est détenue par
la banque centrale européenne un peu
technique mais pas la majorité mais
voilà ces 20 à 25 % 1 5 600 milliards
sont détenus alors que c'est pas son
rôle dans les traités européens la
banque centrale européenne n'a pas le
droit de financer directement les états
mais compte tenu de la pandémie des
situations budgétaires difficiles des
états elle a racheté des titres de dette
dont elle détient de fait elle fait
quelque chose qu'elle n'était pas censé
faire deux par les traités ou alors ça
s'appelle pas la révolution ça s'appelle
assouplissement quantitatif
ça s'appelle le jeu politique
accommodante et
voilà on n'a pas changé les traiter mais
de fait la place trouver un moyen a
changé son rôle on a inventé un truc et
ben inventons un truc pour aller plus
loin autorisons la banque centrale
européenne a financé les états il ya un
projet notamment à l'ordre du jour de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne qui consiste à essayer de
trouver un système de taxation des
géants du numérique pour rembourser en
partie cette dette commune est ce que
vous y êtes favorable ça doit vous
plaire ça bien sûr bien sûr je suis
favorable mais il faut aller jusqu'au
bout parce que déjà on a reculé joe
biden qui a surpris tout le monde il
avait annoncé une taxation
multinationales à 21% voilà deux mois
plus tard c'est arrivé à 15 donc on a
discuté sur la base de 15 % alors après
pour que cet accord soit effectivement
mise en oeuvre il faudra l'accord de
tous tous les états membres de l'union
européenne alors au sein de l'union
européenne il ya des petits états qui
ont des vertus fiscales particulières je
pense à malte je pense à chypre je pense
à l'irlande j'adore l'irlande mais voilà
ces deux ennemis mais un groupe comme
apple il p 0 005 % partout les mécanisme
d'évitement fiscal etc donc comment ces
pays là vont réagir est ce qu'ils vont
signer cet accord pour qu'effectivement
ça se mette en oeuvre
il ya du chemin à parcourir c'est un
combat à mener faut que tout le monde
s'en mêle c'est le sens des bouquins je
dire c'est la sphère de tout le monde
parce que c'est notre avenir je reviens
sur votre livre dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure milliards en fuite manifeste
pour une finance éthique lorsque j'en ai
parlé j'ai une question qui a été posée
par colin qui vous demandaient ce que
parler de finance éthique ce n'est pas
contradictoire
c'est presque une gageur mais c'est un
objectif quoi effectivement quand on
voit toutes les pratiques de l'industrie
financière c'est fabuleux hier je lisais
dans le monde d'hier la bnp paribas a
vendu je sais plus une bonne partie de
ses titres pour pour en faire monter la
valeur et donc augmenter le dividende
des actionnaires pour détruire ses
titres juste après faire dire c'est
c'est la finance qui tourne sur
elle-même voyez vous c'est plus la
finance qui va financer l'économie
réelle la finance s'autoalimente par ces
pratiques absolument délirantes on est
dans un monde complètement débridée
finances des règles finance éthique dans
un monde idéal d'éric bocquet c'est à
dire quoi une finance éthique est ce que
c'est le capitalisme existe toujours
est-ce qu'on peut toujours gagner de
l'argent prétend c'est quoi c'est une
remise en cause de l'usure c'est
dépasser le capitalisme c'est que toute
la richesse produite par l'ensemble de
l'humanité dans tous les pays du monde
servent à l'économie réelle et les
grands besoins les besoins sociaux voilà
on a besoin d'éducation n'a besoin de
santé on a besoin de collectivités on a
besoin de culture pas tout ce qui fait
une société un monde civilisé j'ai
toujours cette phrase henry morgenthau
qui était le secrétaire d'état au trésor
de roosevelt dans un étrange il avait eu
cette phrase l'impôt c'est le prix à
payer pour vivre dans un monde civilisé
voilà une finance qui permet de
construire un monde civilisé un autre
monde qui dépasse le capitalisme ça me
va bien et si voilà un monde idéal entre
guillemets il faut le construire c'est
un combat vous parlez d'un pot et on
revient sur le budget donc qui a été
rejeté par le sénat il se trouve que ce
budget continuait à la traduction de la
politique fiscale d'emmanuel macron pour
la dernière année de son quinquennat à
savoir la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation qui est la grande mesure en
faveur des classes moyennes on va le
dire vite d'emmanuel macron ca attendu
l'esa a tendu les relations entre
emmanuel macron lmr vous avez été maire
pendant quatre mandats vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure
est-ce que la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation était une bonne idée du
président de la république franchement
pas parce que évidemment c'est les
français qui l'appellent ses plaidoyers
bien sûr pour ceux qui la paient voilà
mais il ya d'autres façons de répondre
au pouvoir d'achat des gens au niveau
des salaires des retraites qui ont été
maltraités pendant ce quinquennat un peu
comme avant mais supprimer la taxe
d'habitation c'est encore un levier en
moins pour l'autonomie des collectivités
et notamment des communes quoi
aujourd'hui il nous reste c'est que la
confier ses compensées par l'état quand
même oui mais vous n'avez plus la main
la compensation de l'état c'est lui qui
valent à fixer et est ce que ça sera
maintenue dans la durée on a vu que la
taxe professionnelle quand elle était
supprimé unilatéralement par france
sarkozienne de la sarkozie 2010
on a garanti qu'elle serait compensée à
l'euro près s'est pas tout à fait ça qui
s'est passé voilà donc on perd à chaque
fois un levier fiscal on perd à chaque
fois un outil pour l'autonomie des
collectivités qui est pourtant inscrit
dans la constitution à chaque fois on en
perd un bon il y avait le congrès des
maires de france et quelques jours
emmanuel macron est venu faire le point
si je puis dire dans sa relation avec
les maires on a rappelé quand même qu
emmanuel macron n'a jamais été élu maire
par le passé il a même jamais été élu en
réalité ne lui présente la république
directement
ça avait été montré comme un obstacle au
début est ce que vous pensez que le fait
que le président n'ait jamais été élu
élu local élu parlementaire
ça a été une limite dans l'exercice de
son pouvoir sans doute expliquer une
bonne part des relations difficiles avec
les collectivités des mers et et le
sénat qui est la représentation en
direct des des collectivités parce que
nous sommes élus par les élus locaux
conseils municipaux et départementaux ou
régionaux donc on est l'émanation des
collectivités etc une part de
l'explication d'abord il ya eu un peu de
suffisance et de mépris parfois à
l'endroit du parlement globalement mais
à l'assemblée il a une majorité acquise
mécaniquement neurologue le sujet se
pose moins mais au sénat franchement il
ya eu beaucoup de malentendus beaucoup
de mépris mal vécu les présences très
rare de bruno le maire dans l'hémicycle
ont été désignés c'est un peu
anecdotique mais c'est un peu révélateur
de voilà là dans le débat parlementaire
s'est clairement apparu alors on peut
être un très bon président sans l'être
sans avoir été conseiller municipal
maire ou député c'est pas une condition
absolue c'est surtout le logiciel qu'on
dans la tête acquis répond-t-on lequel
intérêt on défend quoi du coup c'est une
question de colin qui vous demandait ce
qu'on n'arrive pas un peu au bout de la
cinquième république
là vraiment on est au bout de ce système
ça jeu on en fait le constat réglant ce
serait quoi l'idée pour vous d'un
président dans une nouvelle république
se croyait plus fragiles et recel
directe serait plus départ et français
un fanatique de l'élection au suffrage
universel dépendant de la république ok
la deuxième chose c'est que les français
y sont très attachés oui ils sont très
attachés mais j'assume le dire ça le
quinquennat a aussi accéléré la
présidentialisation
l'inversion du calendrier on élit
d'abord le président puis une assemblée
là les gens ont du bon sens ils vont
donner à ce président ou cette
présidente la majorité dont il a besoin
à l'assemblée pour mettre en oeuvre son
programme c'est une question de bon sens
mais le parlement donc quasi l'assemblée
nationale est quasiment godillots voilà
les députés redevable de l'érection
après l'élection du président de la
république
il ya besoin de redonner de la force au
parlement clairement un exemple tout
simple l'article 40 de la constitution
je vais essayer de faire simple vous
déposer un amendement dans la loi de
finances qui augmente une des plats
dépenses de l'état il est frappé de ce
qu'on appelle irrecevabilité parce que
c'est l'article 40 on en discute même
pas la poubelle déposé un amendement wii
qui va générer une dépense mais pour
répondre at elle besoin il faudrait il
faudrait casser ce truc là c'est un
verrou qu'on a mis sur la la capacité du
parlement à modifier le budget savez
quand on discute du budget là on passe
donc des jours et des jours un peu moins
cette fois pour les raisons qu'on a
expliqué on dépose je sais pas 600 700
800 amendements et au bout du bout sur
un budget de 300 milliards de recettes
on a bougé 2 ou 3 milliard sais plus qui
disait si ce budget était la fabrication
d'un véhicule automobile le débat
parlementaire sur le budget a changé un
enjoliveur ces voiliers donc c'est vous
dire à quel point il faut redonner du
poids au parlement à l'assemblée et au
sénat est cassé ce régime présidentiel
verticale qui s'est vraiment accentuée
dans ce quinquennat à partir de janvier
français à partir de janvier prochain
par dont la france assurera là
présidence tournante du conseil de
l'union européenne emmanuel macron a
bien l'intention d'en faire un moment
fort de son quinquennat et on s'en doute
de sa campagne présidentielle également
il a il a l'intention de développer ce
qui la promeut promu comme étant
l'autonomie stratégique de l'union
européenne face notamment aux états unis
et à la chine est ce que la france est
ce que l'union européenne a intérêt à
développer son autonomie stratégique
selon vous ses intérêts propres il faut
d'abord je pense que l'union européenne
devrait être construite là aussi les
traités européens sont à revoir il faut
arrêter
comment dirais-je cet espace de
concurrence libre et non faussée inscrit
dans les traités
écouter les peuples en 2005 on a refusé
la france là le traité européen qui nous
est hétéro servi par la fenêtre quelques
mois plus tard mais par la voie
parlementaire cette fois
oui et la france au sein l'union
européenne devrait avoir un autre rôle
moteur et notamment en termes
d'indépendance par rapport aux états
unis effectivement on l'a vu que
l'épisode dramatique des sous-marins là
est bon c'est édifiant fois ci c'est
affligeant de gaulle doit se retourner
dans sa tombe quoi donc cette europe oui
doit affirmer son autonomie
son identité dans la coopération voilà
pour mettre en place un espace de
coopération et un espace d'harmonisation
fiscale on en a parlé social aussi
surgir et on en parlait tout à l'heure
de la législation sur les géants du
numérique est aussi un autre sujet
qu'emmanuel macron souhaite promouvoir
et qui à l'agenda européen pardon c'est
la taxe carbone aux frontières est-ce
que là aussi l'union européenne qui a
l'ambition d'être le premier continent
du monde neutre en carbone en 2050 est
ce que l'union européenne peut se passer
des
importations pour des raisons de
de production de carbone co2 taxer aux
frontières de l'union européenne du
carbone ça veut dire
ça veut dire réindustrialiser l'europe
parce qu'on doit être obligé de se
passer de tout ce qu'on fait venir
d'asie notamment et oui ça pose cette
question là effectivement c'est on a les
moyens de faire ça c'est un long travail
c'est un chantier qu'il faut ouvrir ça
va pas se faire en deux ans parce que ça
fait des décennies de choix contraire
qu'on fait qu'on paye là quand renault a
choisi de produire ce nouveau véhicule
en chine plutôt qu'en france où au moins
en europe
c'est un sujet c'est un choix on a les
choix qui ont été faits pour des raisons
encore une fois financières de
rentabilité à court terme rentabilité à
deux chiffres mais notre tissu
industriel
s'est délité considérablement il ya un
travail considérable pour le réinstaller
sur notre territoire ou avec nos
partenaires européens mais encore une
fois sur des bases de coopération pas
des bases de concurrence on serait
capable au niveau de l'union européenne
de faire les choses absolument fabuleux
je crois à tgv européen on est capable
de faire ça par exemple une dernière
question pour vous éric bocquet est ce
que vous suivez le foot oui ben et zdf
qui vous vous demandez ce que vous
pensez de la viola montée de la violence
dans les stades notamment après le
fameux match lens lille et c'est
inquiétant ça m'inquiète face et comme
toute cette violence qui se développe
dans la société et donc dans les stades
c'est pas étranger à ce qui se passe
dans la société il ya de la tension il
ya oui les matchs de foot c'est pas les
arènes quoi c'est pas les gladiateurs
c'est un moment de plaisir qui doit être
partagé y compris par des enfants enfin
il ya quarante mille personnes dans un
stade c'est pour passer un bon moment
mais cette violence est inquiétante et
on peut que la condamnée on peut que la
condamnée et puis voilà et il ya des
propos violents dans cette société à
l'endroit de certaines minorités ou
certaines religions au certains peuples
ont peut-être trouvé aussi parce que
peut-être qu'on s'attaque plus
facilement un joueur dans la peau est
noire qu'un joueur dont la peau est
blanche quoi je me suis en angleterre il
ya 20 ou 30 ans où je fais des bananes
sur le terrain de foot il y avait un
corps c'est encore arrivé récemment il
conduit encore il écrit donc c'est pas
nouveau mais ça ça a tendance à se
développer c'est inquiétant il faut être
vigilant par rapport à ça évidemment
j'ai cité lance le match lens lille
puisque éric bocquet et sénateur du nord
mais vous avez raison de parler du match
lyon marseille 1 qui lui aussi a été le
théâtre de violences merci eric bocquet
d'avoir accepté mon invitation merci à
vous d'avoir suivi cette émission de
senna stream vous pourrez la retrouver
sur public sénat le canal 13 de la suède
de la tnt ainsi que sur publicsenat.fr
je vous dis à la semaine prochaine ciao
[Musique]